as you may or may not know I often write
about the battles of history between
Muslims and Christians aside from their
being intrinsically interesting I do so
to shed light on a history that has
otherwise been suppressed and to
demonstrate
continuities that said surely these
battles of bygone days are no longer
having a practical impact on the
development of current events well as it
happens they still are let's look at two
relatively recent examples
we begin with the little known fact that
among all the other reasons Muslims turn
to terrorism avenging lost battles of
history is Apparently one of them
seriously according to a December 2024
report from the Brussels signal three
young men who were said to have been
radicalized have been charged with
alleged criminal terrorist conspiracy by
France's intelligence Services allegedly
inspired by jihadist ideology the
individuals are suspected of planning at
least one violent act in the central
eastern city of potier involving
homemade bombs one of the suspects was a
son of an Imam from the city mosque and
a former Muslim chaplain at the prison
in the St Breton Town one age 19 the
others 20 the three suspects were
students in chemistry psychology and
computer science according to the
investigation by the authorities the
three men allegedly wanted to avenge the
Arab Berber troops defeated in 7 32 by
Charles Martell at the Battle of potier
also known as the Battle of Tours while
much can be said about this let's begin
by considering what it reveals about the
two civilizations in question that of
Muslims and that which was once headed
by men such as Charles The Hammer
Martell the hero of potier or the Battle
of Tours the Battle of Tours in 732 ad
was indeed a watershed moment so much so
that I dedicated an entire chapter to it
in sword and Scimitar chapter 3 I
believe as one leading historian whom I
quoted in that book said that military
encounter was quote one of the great
events in the history of the world as
upon its issue depended whether
Christian civilization should continue
or whether Islam should Prevail
throughout Europe end
quote as such isn't it interesting that
on the one hand Muslims still remember
and seek to avenge themselves against
this battle and on the other most
western people know absolutely nothing
about it Bernard Lewis once explained
this strange
dichotomy he wrote quote most Muslims
unlike most Americans have an intense
historical awareness and see current
events in a much deeper and broader
perspective than we normally do surely
this is putting it mildly if anything
Muslims are increasingly walking in
perfect continuity with their history
one which featured invasions
terrorization conquest of non-muslim
lands and westerners are increasingly
walking in perfect discontinuity with
their history one which featured
Europeans defending against and invading
Muslims all right now let's look at our
second example the city council of
Vienna in the country of Austria refuses
to honor John 3 seski the Polish King
who saved the Austrian capital from the
Turks in
1683 with a statue due to in the words
of one report by the Brussels signal
concerns to do with
islamophobia to appreciate the
significance of all this let's begin by
briefly summarizing the Muslim Siege of
Vienna in 1683 like tours 951 years
earlier also one of the most important
confrontations between Islam and the
west and also like tours it receives an
entire chapter in my book sword and
Scimitar chapter 8 I believe in the
summer of 1683 some 200,000 Muslims
under ottoman Turkish leadership invaded
Austria slaughtering over 30,000
Christian captives in the process and
laying Siege to Vienna for over two
months the hold up and vastly
outnumbered vienes suffered plague
dentry starvation and many casualties
especially among women and children then
on September 12 when the city had
reached its final extremity and the
Muslims were about to burst through
delivery arrived in the words of an
anonymous English
eyewitness after a Siege of 60 days
accompanied with thousand difficulties
sicknesses wants of provisions and great
effusion of blood after a million of
Cannon and musket shot bombs and all
sorts of fireworks which has changed the
face of the fairest and most flourishing
city in the world disfigured and ruined
it Heaven favorably heard the prayers
and tears of a cast down and mournful
people the formidable king of Poland
John sobeski had arrived at the head of
approximately 65,000 Horsemen to avenge
beleaguered Vienna it is not a city
alone that we have to save he had told
his men but the whole of Christianity of
which the city of Vienna is the bul
workk such were his words from a top a
hill overlooking the city before leading
a thunderous downhill cavalry charge in
fact history's largest against the
Muslims and annihilating them many polls
and austrians then and now appreciated
so's heroic relief of of Vienna to the
point that since at least 2013
they have been clamoring for a monument
to the Polish King on the very Hill
where his army had launched its salvic
charge although Vienna initially agreed
to it 12 years ago plans for any
Monument sobeski were recently cancelled
all together why because and to quote
the city council woman Veronica
Cassler Vienna will not erect a stage
which can be abused for xenophobic
agitation and for fomenting islamophobia
and anti-t turkic
sentiment interestingly and despite her
name this Veronica looks much more
turkic than Austrian this would make
sense because after the polls saved the
vienes from Islam in 1683 the vienes
went on to welcome Muslims especially
Turks in the name of Tolerance
multiculturalism diversity and all that
as a result Vienna is now a Bastion of
Islam in side of Europe yes that's right
although once a Catholic City and seat
of the Holy Roman Empire hence why the
Turks were so eager to conquer it as
they were earlier with Constantinople
and also wanted to conquer Rome today
there are more Muslim than Catholic
students in Vienna let that sink in for
a while in light of the aforementioned
history and sacrifices of Christians and
the mosques that the children and their
parents in Vienna attend have repeatedly
been exposed for preaching
radicalization and Hate hatred when two
young Muslim boys were arrested before
launching a terror attack on their
school in 2023 in Austria they confessed
that quote we wanted to shoot all the
Christians in the class why because
quote killing Christians takes us to
Paradise crime as might be expected is
also rampant in Vienna thanks precisely
to this influx of Islam according to a
report titled austrians living in fear
as violent migrant gangs carry out daily
attacks in Vienna
huh muggings and beatings are becoming
commonplace in the historic capital city
with passers by being attacked on almost
a daily basis the prern area just
outside Central Vienna is now controlled
by North Africans and is considered the
worst area in the city for crime despite
police increasing their presence in the
area it has become riddled with crime on
the other side of the city the area
surrounding the West railway station has
been taken over by afghans who have been
making headlines for all the wrong
reasons crimes carried out by migrants
in Austria have risen rapidly over the
past year as more arri in the country
sex attacks carried out by Asylum
Seekers have become a serious problem in
Austria with a
133% increase in migrant sex attacks in
just the past year since the migrant
crisis
erupted indeed as in other European
nations sex crimes including against
young boys have skyrocketed in Austria
according to one report quote hardly a
day goes by without reports of sex
attacks at the hands of migrants after
Afghan migrants tried to rape and
assault a blonde woman police responded
by advising her to dye her hair black
incidentally all these reports and
figures I'm relaying are from 2016 and
2017 since then the Muslim population of
the city has continued to grow as has
the
criminality meanwhile all that the
Austrian government has done in the face
of this demographic reol ution and
Muslim aggression is pretend that it's
not happening School textbooks whitewash
Islamic history including the
aforementioned Siege of Vienna while
demonizing Austria's own intolerant
Christian Heritage austrians are
expected to cancel themselves as a way
to appease Muslims Christmas festivities
are curtailed in Vienna and other Muslim
heavy regions even as Catholic children
are forced to learn and recite Islamic
verse come Ramadan in one instance after
picking up her young son from school one
Catholic mother was shocked to hear him
loudly and repeatedly proclaiming Allah
Allah until she learned that for 2
months the entire class had been
compelled on pain of punishment to
memorize and chant Islamic incantations
it felt like a slap in my face said the
mother in an
interview Little Wonder that a monument
sobeski the Archen enemy of they who now
run Vienna is not allowed in the
Austrian Capital he once so
famous he once so famously saved on The
One hand the masochistic vienes at least
their elected officials do not want to
offend the descendants of those Turks
and Muslims who once terrorized
slaughtered and Enslaved the people of
Vienna and who are themselves currently
criminalizing Vienna on the other hand
they have no problem spitting in the
eyes of the descendants of those
Christian polls who gave their lives to
save Vienna from Islam so there it is
these battles especially the Epic ones I
Chronicle in sword and simitar are not
just dead Tales From the Past but still
having an impact on and revealing much
about the modern world